le coût des sondages et du vote utile je
le dis aux français qui nous écoutent on
nous l'a fait depuis 20 ans à quelques
jours du premier tour de la
présidentielle vous vous demandez
peut-être est-ce que je dois voter selon
mes convictions où est ce que je dois
voter utile selon les sondages une
question qui a souvent animé les
campagnes présidentielles
on parle d'abord de vote utile au sein
d'une même famille politique pour un
candidat qui est bien placé dans les
sondages et qui peut se qualifier au
second tour de la présidentielle c'est
le cas à gauche en 2017 pour jean luc
mélenchon en pleine dynamique avant le
premier tour face à un benoît hamon en
perte de vitesse il est devenu une sorte
de vote utile de conviction à gauche ça
je le crois en effet annoncé pas le vote
utile c'est l'asse les rapports de force
1 je pense qu'aujourd'hui le vote de
conviction utile à gauche est en train
de se cristalliser autour de jean-luc
mélenchon voilà et cinq ans plus tard on
entend de nouveau cette petite musique
d'un vote utile à gauche pour jean luc
mélenchon alors qu'il devance nettement
dans les sondages les autres candidats
de gauche le vote utile c'est aussi un
argument utilisé par certains pour
éviter que l'extrême droite se
qualifient au second tour de la
présidentielle et en 2010 est celui qui
incarne le vote utile face à marine le
pen c'est emmanuel macron et ça ne plaît
pas beaucoup aux autres candidats et à
leurs soutiens l'ennemi numéro 1 c'est
le front national et jeu c'est important
de le plus aisé vous nous dites votre
ennemi numéro 1 votre ennemi principal
assez non mais mais en mon nom je refuse
l'argument qui consiste à dire faut
voter utile dès le premier tour puisque
certains agitent cette menace du front
national dès le premier tour non soyons
clairs il n'y a pas de menace front
national au premier tour le vote utile
c'est aussi une expression que détestent
les petits candidats qui se sentent
disqualifié par leur faible sondage
écouter nicolas dupont aignan le coût
des sondages et du vote utile je le dis
aux français qui nous écoutent on nous
l'a fait depuis 20 ans et à chaque fois
c'est ce qui a permis à des gens
incompétents et corrompus de rester au
pouvoir alors je vous le dis très
clairement le vrai vote utile c'est le
vote par adhésion eu de conviction alors
écoutez vos convictions ou regarder les
sondages l'important c'est d'aller voter
dimanche
[Musique]